i just told him you know i was that  close to calling a timeout  in those situations i have to trust  his ability to make the pass with the  shepherd  and tonight he made shot after shot and  that last one was  pretty cool to watch i mean that's a lot  that's a big confidence booster  uh we wanted to get the last shot though  you know after we got the steal  um and the ball with 10 seconds i just  want to make sure i took the last shot  giving them no time on the what happened  i knew the double team was coming  so i attacked opposite way there's a lot  of length over there with kawhi so come  faith got him in the air  i'm not a big celebration guy seen me in  the past when i hit a big shot  but they caught me on the ground so i  couldn't get away from them  usually in the past i hit a big shot you  know i just want to move on to the next  game and get off the court  but they caught me while i was down